welcome to this video playing only X
from turkey one of the guys where I have
a really bad score two losses a two wins
for losses one draw if I read that
correctly 21 read that correctly I'm
sorry Walden yeah two wins two wins for
losses not too great I think he's
playing the external not now I had
somehow had the memory that he placed
the exchange but he didn't so we get to
the classical probably classical we see
three what else a four they have a form
some an alternative news now yeah h3
maybe i don't i don't remember it's been
ages since I've studied that I'm not
sure at all yeah okay I don't think this
what i'm doing here is necessarily the
best way to play but it should be a
playable way gaining space on the
queenside the question is night g3 h3 do
i retreat the bishop on what do i do
them d for a quickie before I mean
sometimes before us also
also that see form I'm going to go see
form trying to block the bishop the
bishop is a bit strange on a tool maybe
this is some playable option Bishop to
e6 no 10 all the way back to the Sun I'm
okay uncie form I have covered it but I
need to probably play whoopsie 8 in the
future to support see form this I didn't
expect rename I'm threatening night b3
now winning the exchange ok it should be
six yeah covering see form and renewing
this threat I couldn't play it
immediately Knight takes pawn takes
Queen takes them I couldn't do it
immediately right hmm but now night b3 I
don't really think that this was so
great for wide it's quite an annoying
threat maybe he must play a move like
would be one getting out of this
yeah i'm going to go light be three
let's say after Queenie to it is so
development is clocked up so not clear
what you should do yeah not not a very
attractive move but maybe what you
needed to do ok I'm going to cover the
seafoam prophylactically but it's not so
apparent how I should continue I mean it
looking nice but what is my plan night
night to d3 could be an idea of 9075
this type of idea 97 Bishop g5 oh this
this is getting more attractive after F
395 now maybe not maybe 95 coming ok
let's cover this let's cover the square
I don't want I don't want a knight
coming there and after capture the codec
we're taking with the Queen this is so
not not nice sure ok c4 is this very
good nicely protected now if I return
here what is he going to do Roque one
and maybe then we'll see a 95 bank and
then 93 yeah this is okay this looks
like and I'm like an ammonia set up 93
yeah I always have night f4 if he tries
to use a tactic here night a full
don't know if this is how really helping
i also have d5 but I don't know this
this is not good I think it's just this
just helps him okay play a strengthening
move I don't see something great at the
moment it's good for my back rank and f5
has colored stuff like that I didn't see
yeah I thought this was not possible I
mean maybe I could have taken but this
is a thing just winning this piece
and white resigns yeah I think I had a
good position anyway but I don't I
didn't really see how to to make a
decisive progress this is a well g6 is
just a bit of a strengthening move oh
the computer is showing the way Brooke
a7 of course it's very easy just this
rookie 8 a-8 and get the bishop why does
even worse than I thought yeah this is
minus minus 4 yeah i'm just getting the
bishop very easy yeah so okay yet he
could have played b3m limiting the
danger but it's still am a winner
according to the computer but not so so
clear as rook a 7 watts and this just
just gives up a piece I really don't
know if this kind of transformation is
so good it feels like he's got really a
bad Bishop Ian especially after that I
mean it's it's just very passive and he
does not get the sea for porn this can
only be an idea if he really is winning
the porn that he is not down here moves
like d hive already I interesting but I
didn't want to open it up early I just
always keep this advantage of the bishop
you know yeah I think this is okay so
it's minus four already according to the
comp ruka a 5 root k dad I just didn't
see this immediate idea rook a
five-night takes through k2 voix and
black is completely winning oh nice okay
thanks for watching